una vez más a italia después de que el
jefe del gobierno italiano mario draghi
presentó este jueves su dimisión al
presidente italiano sergio matar el a
este último no aceptó la renuncia de
draghi y le solicitó que trate de
encontrar una nueva mayoría en el
parlamento italiano que le permita
continuar con su mandato detrás de
bambalinas las negociaciones entre
fuerzas políticas italianas no han
parado si no logran en llegar a un
acuerdo con mario draghi el presidente
italiano matare la podría nombrar otro
primer ministro o también convocar
elecciones anticipadas en italia
hipótesis que hacen temer una crisis
política que cae en un muy mal momento
para el país sometido a fuertes
presiones económicas a causa de la
inflación la plan demia y una crisis
energética consecuencia del bloqueo del
gas ruso a europa para tratar de salir
de este laberinto político mario draghi
pronunciara un discurso ante el
parlamento italiano el próximo miércoles
día en el cual se valorará
el actual gobierno dispone de una
mayoría en el parlamento que le permita
seguir en pie